I've shown it's a relative minimum all
right so now what do I have to do to
show that it's the minimum of all things
I've got to keep mind all these right
now are there any other turning points
all right you just got to eat no I doing
points because the X&Y a lot of it now
this is tricky right remember I asked
you to note this down okay we actually
didn't note down everything and because
positive integers right and they add up
to eight okay so positive implies okay
there's a certain by can't go any
smaller than that but there's also a bar
that it can't go bigger than that right
if they're both positive integers what's
the biggest one of the numbers could
possibly be eight right though sort of
not really right because because if it's
a positive integer right if one of
them's ate the other one will be zero
which is not a positive integer is a
positive zero zero is not a pleasant one
so what I should really say here and
this might be a better way to put in
what descriptive way is that 4x I have
this domain right note that it's not
inclusive copy is here and I can't be at
a Tyler because being at eight makes the
other 10 same domain for why okay are
you happy with that here's the tricky
thing um these right you see how you
never actually get to the end right you
never get to zero and any small value
you pick like 0.1 it was your point zero
one you can with your character says
true I can't actually go any further
right so my real endpoints are actually
one and seven right so even better this
because they're integers I could say
this
sorry okay be careful now do you see how
much thought goes into it's such a
simple setup right you'll be careful all
right now I'm going to test my endpoints
I have to test my endpoints right so I'm
going to test I actually don't need to
test both of them because i have n just
as a function of one of them okay so
i'll test y equals 1 i'll test y equals
7 so here's what I've got I'm actually
going to put together a little table for
myself okay much like when I test
derivative on either side I'm going to
have Y and my value for M okay so what
am I end points 1 and 7 what values am I
going to get let's see Cruz my function
here it is so if i put in 1 i'm going to
get 2-16 as minus 14 464 650 if i put in
seven it should actually be 50 as well 2
times 49 it's 98 minus 16 x 2 is 32 so
90 8-32 sorry all right of course + 7 x
16 16 is time to dance through 400 1212
I should really write this down tonight
98-85 plus 64 okay what we expected so i
can now verify that my endpoints are no
better than before I really should have
stuck this in the middle
ok so now you can see this table all it
does is it helps me to compare that's
all that's all it's doing so is there
still necessary if you use the same
people so that's the derivative
interesting on either side already yeah
it is I still got to go for input still
going to go there well because in this
case what if it's just a booth end point
sadly I want to see what if we tested
with and that's complete for tested walk
with endpoints you mean the armor first
derivative ah now I would caution
against that they actually mention this
very quickly in the exam maybe you
missed this on when you're testing the
first written on either side okay number
one you won't get a value for n you'll
get a value for DN on dy there's the
first problem secondly if you test the
endpoints you're so far away from the
station point that other stuff could
happen in between right so it's not a
valid you'd have to go close off like
three and five or even three point nine
and four point five is better ok
well right okay what also because of a
better way to save in shape is the fact
that is just one stationary point and
it's it's concave up okay now again I'm
trying to illustrate the way you go
through the question with a simple
example that you could have solved this
in your mate it is when you did
quadratics and maximum and minimum value
suppose you just find the vertex but
those methods won't work when you've got
a more complicated function okay so I'm
doing the whole big little just for this
question will we still need to do that
doable if it was just this question
which is actually a pretty typical
question and it appeared in a year 11 i
do that very likely say approved by
calculus if they don't say that though
we're gonna need that i Justi the whole
using still like three or four marks I
think you're pushing it but especially
if if if it's all they're looking to a
pot apply marks to all of these little
bits right so you probably a maximum too
if you just said here's the number and
because it's a quadratic okay it's the
minimum because love yeah but then
they're clearly number one it's it's
clearly implying that they want you to
show it in a more rigorous ray number
two you're in year 11 and want you to
show that you understand calculus that's
what they're testing right with what if
they have like calculus course just
there will be lots of calculus questions
and this will still be tested by
calculus why you need to be a credible
let's go up buddy anyway I'm always
there we need to put a conclusion
together
it's just in case oh you must have to
help you saturday alright let's finish
okay so now that I've got my stationary
point I showed its value I can say since
now do you remember is this beautiful
peridot few miles then go hard I don't
say you can do this another this is the
only station in white good good which it
is continuity continue reading can
continue facility that's good this is
the early station boy and the function
is continuous don't forget the domain
okay a relative minimum and this is
getting your question Richard is also
the absolute ah yeah if it's
differentiable and wise so if it's a
differentiable after we continuously
differentiable means the derivative is
continuous if the derivative is
continuous that means the function is
continuous but it was a continuous it's
not necessarily differentiable correct
because piecewise functions right like
the absolute value of x it's continuous
their holes in it but at that point at
the origin you can't differentiate it
because when you take the limit from
both sides you get totally different
values now what is the smallest player
go forever therefore they ask you the
question in the center so you should add
some in a sentence smallest value for in
hey person now admittedly I felt like a
long time follow because we've kind of
got caught up it's on the minor details
but that's what you expected to produce
okay and again I'm doing it for a simple
quadratic question so when you get likes
a cubic or some other weird kind of
variety question you'll know what to do
okay okay because i actually just rubbed
it off so N equals right and you've got
that function there and you don't need
to prove its continuity don't approve
you can just say it is continuous what
we're looking for is the fact that you
recognize that this is important right
because you will get sometimes
discontinuations and you have to account
for that so it gives you more n points
basic yeah good for you in yeah yeah he
said it was a no necessary to like like
you said it was no hmm that's right is
that always okay let me think yes yeah
all the way up to the hrc the reason why
it's in the program is because you need
to understand it it's because of this
topic because continuity has
implications for whether something is a
matter it's in the n-word cetera you
don't need to prove it you just need to
know what it is and how to fix your
answer